hello welcome to see you're playing
Grand Master my anguish not pronouncing
this correctly because I feel that it
wasn't his intention how it should be
pronounced okay so yeah this is an
interesting line 97 interesting for both
sides actually let's do it like this he
is not playing castles as h5 is an
option is also why didn't castle so be
formed probably okay so b5 his guys
going Knight a5 and so first of all he
is taking and then 95 mm-hmm okay so
spend a little more
maybe just castle
my ideas to go here and now okay I
didn't think about that who I should
have I was on tonight a 5 which is
ridiculous of course 98 makes a lot more
sense okay okay one is a tactically
motivated move in some way as now c6 can
be answered with v6 and I'm winning
material and um strategically speaking I
think I'm threatening b5 hmmm that's re
b5 b6 it's not easy for him he cannot
move the rook as the bishop Hanks the
bishop morning the bishop drops the rock
song and he cannot move a night as p7
hang so it's a little bit awkward for
him so yeah this feels good there now be
six you can take with the bishop still
it's a little bit looks a little bit
clumsy Queen a4 is actually renewing
this idea can go Bishop g7 though yeah
maybe I'm it's a little bit on the crowd
side ok now it's a good move home of
course I can just turn can just connect
down and now is threatening to take some
I was pretty bad a quick relay for was a
pretty awful idea
pretty pretty awful
96 was a useful move I'm so provoking
that it's pretty pretty wrong we add
that I didn't didn't notice that okay
okay then Bishop h3 actually would work
where to put it pb2 maybe for some
deform yeah that could be useful
actually
also covering the rook which is probably
useful yeah this was something I wasn't
sure about it all that's what to make of
this yeah I go e4 and then put a knight
on d5 okay I had my dad
yeah I've now the porn would pee on f 2
over and then I would be fine very fine
they have to connect rooks I mean I
don't like to move into this diagonal
but I have no choice mascot Bishop five
or something no hmm this one really ok I
have good night at five it's now ah I
just forgot that he can take oh my god
I'm really losing focus here can you go
g6 I was thinking Queen g-queen ac3 but
whoa it might he might still be able to
do it him I'm not check meeting him oh
oh oh yeah yeah g6 I have to go quit 93
which is not great yeah just use sex as
per as possible or Bishop Jesus p should
know we should just have this ridiculous
can I get a sacrifice it somehow check
check check check
laughs let's check this I'm check
checking him here
check so I was thinking the Jason Bishop
e2 and you can move the bishop probably
yeah it's going to be not going to be
fun for him Bishop c8 maybe time warning
sure six is winning check checkmate whoo
yeah I don't know it was a pretty awful
game in some way Queen a force you to
was what was wrong was wrong I'm happy
with this I think this is a this is
decent but I should just play a normal
move now castles or something Queen a4
is pretty pretty awful it just gives
away a temple yeah and now this is
necessary Yuri maybe I shouldn't do this
I know I've helped this was interesting
and then he played this brutal f5 pretty
amazing yeah I have to their computers
kind of agreeing here that is about
equal ish and now it gives I know it
finds widest better you know I simply
did not see that here he can take
everyone I mean it's ridiculous as it
sounds I just didn't see it I should do
this check to get to the F file and then
night f5 mean okay
next on and here white should be a bit
better and the engine gives 0.3 call it
equal whatever yeah now create when a
force to move that he should play and
now is better get here I just went for
it and actually the reputation is Knight
takes e4 which I generally think of
night exe phone and he justice winning
oops oops yeah and this this does win
king age seven is good for black that's
that's a cold-blooded defense here but
it's stronger I can have no move and the
computer wants to do this which is then
relatively best but it drops a big born
so in Jackie I am winning now check
check with the spear should be tuned so
was that checkmate that was lucky very
lucky win okay well thanks for watching